welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is David Cameron a professor of
political science and the director of
the Yale program in European Union
studies currently Europe is facing an
unprecedented humanitarian crisis day
after day thousands of refugees from
Syria Iraq and other countries have
undertaken long and perilous journeys
both across the Mediterranean and
through the Balkans in the hope of
finding shelter and obtaining asylum in
the European Union every day we hear of
one EU state after another instituting
border controls some quite drastic to
stop the flow of migrants and day after
day we hear about disagreements among
the members of the EU over how to
respond to the crisis including how to
share in the burden of receiving the
migrants as we speak the heads of state
and government of the 28 EU member
states are gathering in Brussels for an
emergency meeting to discuss what to do
about the ongoing situation professor
Cameron joins us today to help us
unravel this crisis welcome professor
Cameron Thank You Marilyn it's good to
be here yes and you've been here a
number of times and we appreciate that
to talk about the EU crisis and
specifically Greece so let's start with
Greece they just you know they have
migration issues as well with migrants
coming from Turkey and they've also just
had an election so bring us up to speed
there okay Greece called an election in
August after they obtained approval of
the EU bailout which was negotiated in
July very difficult negotiation you may
recall there was a referendum that
Alexis tsipras called on July fifth a
large majority over sixty percent said
they didn't want the EU conditions the
next day he called a meeting of five
party leaders and they
agreed that they would agree to a
bailout and those parties would support
the government in negotiating the
bailout and approving the plan but only
at that point only up to that point so
they got the approval of the bailout in
August in the course of doing that about
30 of the series of the governing party
the hard left governing party about 30
of the MPS members of parliament voted
against the government and decided to
leave cereza and form their own left of
the left party and at that point tsipras
knew that he had lost his governing
majority which was very thin so he
called a new election the election the
election took place on sep tember 20th
all of the polls said it would be very
close between serezha and New Democracy
and an estimated they were basically
even and it wasn't clear serezha would
be able to form a government as it
turned out the polls were wrong serezha
got almost the same percentage of the
vote that it got in January likes his
Latin about thirty six percent but
because of a quirk in the electoral
system the largest party gets an
additional 50 seats it's it is it is a
quirk it's the proportional
representation quite a nice quirk
party's over three percent but the
leading party gets an additional 50 so
they still didn't have enough to former
majority but they were able to form a
majority with a small right-wing party
that is against austerity so
ideologically it's not even close to
serezha but both parties are against
austerity so we now have a new
government Alexis tsipras is back he's
feeling victorious and actually not very
much has changed from where we were in
January although we've had an enormous
amount of
of drama and uncertainty about this now
the hard work starts they have to
actually implement all of the reforms
and conditions that the EU required in
return for getting the 86 billion and
whether that happens is anyone's guess
at this point yes because one of the
reasons tsipras was voted in was because
he said we would not stand for those
measures of austerity and now it seems
like they're back right at square one
again with the same yes Garrity measures
in place so it seems somewhat crazy they
are well it's a Greek story and it just
goes on and they now they now have to
implement us austerity they will soften
it a bit and the EU will let them soften
it a bit from what it was before but
they have to privatize big sections of
the economy certain firms that are
state-owned they have to cut spending
they have to raise taxes there's a lot
of raising of taxes in the program that
the EU is prepared for Greece it's hard
though to raise those taxes when so many
people are out of work well I mean it
seems it seems an impossible situation
to fix and it's hard to cut spending to
Greece is essentially in a depression
has been in a depression for five years
very high rates of unemployment
especially youth unemployment but
throughout the entire economy and
cutting spending and raising taxes in
the midst of a depression is not the way
you get out the way you get out is you
spend more in you tax less and you put
money in the pockets of the people and
create demand in the economy so why is
that not being done well the EU thinks
this is the way to go and they have a
they have a some might even say a fetish
with balanced budgets or near balanced
budgets and three percent deficit ratio
to GDP as a maximum a target so if
that's your target and the
he's been spending well over that then
you keep telling them to institute more
austerity and the problem is the economy
has been going down and contracting so
in your deficit to gdp ratio the
denominator is shrinking the economy is
shrinking so the deficit is large so
they have to keep cutting and it really
is a never-ending process it's a it's
it's a problem that I think is one that
has caused a great deal of pain and in
Greece and it seems like it's just going
to lead to disaster frankly eventually
they I think we'll get out of it but the
problem now that the government faces is
that they have an enormous amount of
debt over two hundred percent of GDP by
next year and the debt isn't sustainable
they can't pay all of that debt back and
all of that debt is owed to the official
creditors the EU the European Central
Bank the International Monetary Fund and
Greece would like debt relief but that
means giving a haircut as they call it
to the official creditors and the
official creditors don't want that so
there's going to be we're not out of the
woods yet in terms of in terms of the
eurozone crisis at least for Greece and
how long do you think it'll be before
you know we see a sign of whether it's
working or it's clearly not going to
work well I think I think we'll see a
very gradual process of very slow
recovery over in the next several years
it will be a long process a lot of
people who have lost their jobs probably
won't get their jobs back it's going to
be a very difficult time it'll be a
difficult time for serezha and for a
tsipras to govern in part because a lot
of the people while well there was a
defection of a group called the left
platform there's still a lot
people in cereza who were opposed to
austerity opposed to the eurozone
dictatorship as they call it one Greece
to drop out of the eurozone and and it
dot the new currency of its own don't
want to pay the debt back want debt
relief so there is a lot of internal
dissension within the government and
there's a lot of distrust and
disaffection in the population as a
whole the election had the lowest
turnout rate in the history of the
country they're probably saying why
bother nothing's going to change I mean
and let me ask this since we're going to
start talking about the migrant issue
because of the such thing of the
severity of the austerity measures do
you foresee the people of Greece
actually becoming migrants as well if
they can't find work going to different
countries that's an interesting question
I think for some who can get work
elsewhere they will do that young people
with skills and they obviously can move
for their part of the EU their part of
the right Schengen accord in the EU
which is free movement across borders
single internal market applies to the
movement of people as well as goods and
services according to the EU and they've
instituted through the Schengen Accord
of nineteen eighty-five ninety they've
instituted free movement so young people
with skills could certainly go but a lot
of people who are older a lot of people
who perhaps don't have the skills needed
in the job markets elsewhere in Europe
and of course one of the problems is all
of the countries in Europe are
experiencing relatively low growth
they're not they're not doing well
they're not doing as well as well with a
few exceptions the UK's been doing
pretty well but that wasn't responsive
Germany a lot jaan and there were of
course many many people who want to go
to Germany right now so I think it's
it's a time when many people in Greece
are quite are disappointed disaffected
think they've gone through nine months
of drama with no consequence and they
have the same old government back which
is going to be doing something has to do
a policy that it doesn't really believe
in and it's it's not a good situation
for Greece okay so let's look at the
migration crisis why are so many trying
to get to Europe well the problem is I
guess the way to think about this is
start with the Syrian war the civil war
that began four years ago more than four
years ago and we have something on the
order of 10 million people in Syria
who've been displaced lost their homes
there about four million refugees from
Syria two million of them in Turkey
million in Jordan a million in Lebanon
the refugee problem has just become
impossible for those countries the
international donors haven't given
enough given their the contributions
they promised to the UN High Commission
and refugees and so the where the
refugees have gone is a place it's not
very comfortable for them at all and
becoming much more difficult for them
now they might be willing to stay there
if they thought the war was going to be
resolved anytime soon and they could go
home but it's clear the war is getting
worse and Isis is doing very well in
Syria over the past year and is making
rather dramatic gains within Syria in
fact they've even they're approaching
Damascus which i think is one reason the
Russians are going in to try to create a
little enclave for their friend Assad
and when he has to quickly run from
Damascus which will happen in the next
few months I think so from the point of
view of the refugees where they are now
is really not a very good situation at
all because they're not getting the the
carer the attention the food the
medicine medical supplies that they need
in the refugee camps in Turkey Jordan
and Lebanon because the international
aid has been insufficient and they
looked at well and then they well the
donors just haven't come through with as
much as they wildly underestimated how
much they would need no one anticipated
there would be four million refugees in
the nearby countries so the aid has been
insufficient and the country's thus far
I haven't contributed the additional
amount then the refugees look at Syria
and they look at the war and they look
at what's happening in the war and they
realize they're never going to go back
they're never going to be able to go
back the odds that we will have a
peaceful settlement in Syria so that all
of those four million can go home is
unrealistic now and many of them have
lost their homes the war has been
immensely damaging to the housing stock
in the cities and the towns in series so
they look at this situation and a
rational refugee then says well I'm
going to go to Europe where I can get
asylum and so that's been a big I think
it's a sort of a push from given the
developments in the Syrian war and the
situation of refugees and those nearby
countries so does the EU have a policy
for asylum seekers well it does it has a
policy the problem is the policy hasn't
been implemented and and is really not
capable of dealing with the numbers that
we're seeing now I mean the OECD is
estimating that there will be a million
refuge
is coming to europe this year and about
five hundred thousand of them will be
legitimate asylum seekers and and will
get asylum within the EU the EU is
committed to providing asylum meaning
international protection and they've
made it clear that that applies to
everyone who's Syrian but it applies
also to those fleeing Iraq those fleeing
eritrea those three countries are the U
has said are eligible anyone from those
countries is eligible for asylum now the
way it works is the state which receives
the asylum seekers the first state the
frontline state is supposed to register
the people fingerprint them take their
application process the application and
while they're there give them a
temporary residence and if their
application is accepted give them
residence permits for several years the
problem is Greece hasn't done that at
all and I know this is somewhat
facetious to say but basically the
policy of the tsipras government in
dealing with the refugees Syrian
refugees coming from Turkey has been to
put up a road sign pointing to Macedonia
and and just telling them to go north to
Macedonia and then they go through
Macedonian north to Serbia and then they
get too hungry and of course we've seen
what's happened in hungry which has felt
overwhelmed and put up barbed wire
fences and so forth so they've taken a
left at hungry and gone to Croatia and
Croatia's received something like 70,000
refugees and you know in the past week
and it's overwhelmed as well all of the
countries now are putting up border
controls and
if they're if they're good Europeans of
putting up border controls reasserting
border controls which Schengen the free
movement provisions allow in emergencies
there are some countries such as hungry
an outlier which is building fences and
is now building a fence having built the
fence between itself and serbia's
building one between itself and Romania
and one between itself and in Croatia so
the Balkans are having a great deal of
difficulty dealing with this and it's
been in that context that the Interior
Minister is justice and Home Affairs
ministers met yesterday and the leaders
of the EU are meeting today and what do
you think the outcome will be well
yesterday we had a really very
interesting and unusual meeting prior to
the prior to that meeting the EU had
agreed starting last spring and through
the summer to develop a plan to
distribute the refugees on a quota basis
to all of the Member States and they
plan to distribute 40,000 from Italy and
Greece to the Member States and this was
prompted by the flow that came across
the Mediterranean last spring when the
boat loads were coming across and people
were many boats were sinking they were
terrible boats they a lot of them were
over overloaded they were people were
drowning so several thousand people died
in the course of that and at that point
Greece and Italy which were the prime
recipients of the refugees had this plan
developed or the EU developed it to
relieve them by taking the refugees and
distributing them throughout the EU it
was basically similar to a plan the
Germans developed in 1949
used again in 1989 when they got a flow
of people coming from the east used it
again in the Balkans wars of the early
90s in which Germany developed a formula
to distribute silam seekers throughout
the country taking into account of for
example distributing among the states
according to the wealth of the other the
tax revenues of the of the state and the
size of the states within Germany and
they've basically adapted that to the EU
so that we they now have a quota for
those 40,000 well for the last several
weeks there's there have been debates
going on at the ministerial level about
that some of the states don't want any
quotas some of the states don't want it
to meet mandatory wanted to be voluntary
and then as the crisis got worse with
the flow from Turkey to Greece to the
Balkans over the summer and early fall
the European Commission its civil
service came up with a plan for
distributing another 120,000 people in
addition to the 40 so making this a
total of 160,000 and this has created
even more difficulty for some of the
states now yesterday I know I'm going on
just a quick question are they putting
these migrants into camps giant camps or
you know how are they integrating them
into the country in some way well no and
that's a that's a real that's a real
issue i mean what we've seen in
especially in Hungary where they weren't
giving them they had no camps really
they put some after several days or
weeks they put a number of people coming
into so-called transit camps that were
really just fenced-in yards but you
remembered all the scenes of people
being jammed into trains and and they
were just passing them on to the next
country Croatia has over the last week
has been much more supportive in a way
they've developed transit camps they've
taken people by bus from the Hungarian
border a Serbian border 22 to the
transit camps given them showers and
clothes and blankets and food medical
attention and then have bust them on
continuing on their path but it's a real
problem and so one of the problems in
this crisis is the turkey Jordan Lebanon
can't can't man and staff and care for
the refugees in the way they should be
and and even the international agencies
aren't doing enough a second problem is
the frontline States that are receiving
them aren't doing what they're supposed
to be doing under Schengen and they
aren't providing any care so in Greece
there's been really nothing done for the
refugees arriving and they don't want to
stay there they want to go on and of
course what they have beckoning them at
the end of the road is a Germany and
Angela Merkel to her credit has said we
will accept all Syrians and she said
that before she knew exactly how many
would would take her up on that offer so
Germany is now instituting controls the
controls that that any state is supposed
to institute to check and make sure this
person is really a legitimate asylum
seeker as opposed to simply someone who
is seeking an economic opportunity and
and sort of in the midst of the asylum
seekers so the I guess
the second major problem in addition to
dealing with the refugees in the near
country countries near to Syria the
second problem is how do you deal with
the frontline States that are we just
because of geography are the ones there
bear the brunt so clearly one of the
things the leaders will be doing today
will be to provide assistance for
countries such as Italy and Greece which
are receiving the refugees to give them
additional funding and staffing because
Greece in particular with everything
else it's been dealing with has just not
thrown up its arms and and said it's
been unable to cope with the numbers so
let me ask you this we you have a number
of thousands of people entering into the
country where are they going where are
they sleeping how do they eat well
they're there it's a it's a terrible
terribly difficult situation for all of
them because they don't know where
they're going they don't know where
they'll be allowed to go they don't know
where they'll be staying many of them
have had to pay smugglers and human
traffickers to make this long trip
series of trips with smugglers and
people making money on on this at every
turn so it's a very difficult situation
for them and the real problem in the EU
in addition to dealing with the refugee
camp crisis in addition to dealing with
the frontline crisis and after the
relocation crisis is what happens what
do the states do for these refugees they
need language training obviously they're
there Arabic speakers say they will need
to know some German or Swedish or
wherever they end up they'll need
language training they'll need housing
they'll need jobs they'll need all of
the effort of the states to integrate
them in some
way into their societies their economy
as well and and so that's a third area
that the EU will be talking about today
in the meeting of the leaders because
relocating the refugees is fine you
disperse them through all the states
sharing the burden now it is the case
that not all of the states have agreed
and yesterday's meeting of Ministers was
very interesting because we had a vote
where they adopted this plan for another
120,000 despite the opposition of four
states of the Czech Republic Slovakia
Romania and Hungary and I can't think of
any any decision that's been taken at
the ministerial level in the EU that
didn't involve just rather mundane
legislation and administrative matters
that has actually been done by a
majority vote rather than by consensus
which is the way they normally operate
especially when it involves an executive
decision that really involves national
sovereignty it's unusual to have an
up-or-down vote where you're either in
the majority are you not and a couple of
the countries that said no no to the
quotas and note to this quota system
have threatened to take the European
Union to the European Court of Justice
and challenge it Wow so it's it's quite
a historic yeah I'd almost say it was a
historic vote yesterday in that France
and Germany in particular just insisted
that there be a vote an up-and-down vote
on this quota system and that the
countries agree and getting Poland to
agree was an absolutely essential
priority because the way they vote they
have a complicated a weighted voting
system that takes into account the
population of the state
in it's called qualified majority voting
and once Poland was on board with
Germany and France they had the seventy
percent or so that they needed for that
majority to make it that every all of
the 28 so now it applies to everyone so
even Serbia and the ones that did not
well serbia serbia and and macedonia
aren't yet members there on the track to
membership the ones who descended and
but the other want to so now they're
going to be forced to all may all are
allowed to participate in this plan
because they voted it and and they
proved it so it's now a decision taken
by the council now that will be a big
issue that will come up today because
these states will come in and say that
we're not going to do this in fact the
prime minister of Slovakia has already
said we will not be taking any one any
refugee under this quota system as long
as I'm Prime Minister you know why is
that I mean well it's is an ethnicity
thing it's it's a cultural it's a
cultural ethnicity it's a religious
thing they've said at one point I think
one of the ministers said they would
only take Christians they didn't want to
take anyone who is Muslim and of course
we're talking about an overwhelmingly
Muslim a country and group of refugees
so it's it's ethnicity its religion its
cultural difference in distinction it's
you know it's we've we've seen it in
this country everywhere in the world
least and uh it's it's something the
Europeans aren't proud of who see this
among the European states especially for
people who are suffering so much anat
land going through so much and
and and it it shows that beneath the
facade of European solidarity when you
get to really tough issues there often
is not a consensus and and there are
different views of what is in the
national interest which makes things
very difficult well I could talk to you
all day about this hopefully you know
the leaders and them and the ministers
will come up with some kind of plan that
will help these thousands of migrants I
think now for the first time
unfortunately it's taken so long but for
the first time the european union with
the leaders meeting today will deal with
the problem of the refugee camps
bordering Syria the frontline States
they also need to deal with the Balkan
states went through which the refugees
have been moving and they need some
assistance they need to put this quota
system in place and then they have to
deal with the last point that we're
talking about about integrating the
refugees into the country's once once
they are located wherever they end up
being located wrong so it's a huge
challenge huge challenge Angela Merkel
had said this crisis makes the eurozone
crisis as important as it was pale in
comparison right well thank you so much
for being here with us ok for more
information about professor Cameron and
his research please visit our website at
macmillan report yale edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale